what's going on reject nation we're
going to watch today from the cosmic
wonder
spider-man 3 title revealed and
confirmed
spider-verse i'm excited to check this
video out before we go into that i
actually want to shout out a video my
brother did wasn't planning on this but
i watched it last night it's called
working on marvel he basically
interviewed
a friend of his who has worked as a
stunt man stunt coordinator
choreographer of wide variety of roles
on a bunch of marvel movies and it's
actually a
very fascinating in-depth interview he
didn't ask me
to shout this out i watched it last
night i'm like i gotta shut this out at
some point it kind of reminded me like a
quarter crew video in some way for like
stunt men react
so i would really go check that video
out guys i'll put a link in the
description box and pin comment i really
do think it's worth it
anywho let's see what the title is now
that there's so much
trending i'm seeing spider-man 3
trending on twitter a lot these days
people already rolling with it that
andrew garfield and you know toby
mcguire are
officially in it but i haven't heard an
official statement yet
even though i believe it already there's
a great eric
vos twitter thread about this
it going everybody it's warren welcome
back to my channel the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and it looks like the
marvel cinematic universe really
is truly about to be blown wide open
i'm sure by now most people know that
spider-man 3 is looking to be a
huge multiverse movie with the
possibility of it starting the
spider-verse
or at least it being set up doctor
strange is confirmed to be in spider-man
3 and so was electro
jamie foxx's electro from the amazing
spider spider cat then of course you
have
multiple reports stating that andrew
mcguire's spider-man and toby mcguire
special anchor mcguire
maguire but filming forces
so we should be finding out a lot more
about the film
very very soon including the title
but it seems like we may have actually
already discovered
what the title is and if this is the
true title which somebody from a pretty
big website
is claiming that it is it does in fact
describe a multiverse so let's talk
about the title and what it means but
first be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating to the mcu
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway
for a chance to win an iron spider funko
pop that's a great looking [ __ ]
title is coming from the twitter account
ya boy ant-man
this person's name is frankie and he's a
writer for discussing
film a pretty big website that has been
right about a lot of reports in the past
and this person tweeted you're not
following them spider-man
home worlds remember where you hey
that's a cool title spider-man 3 is
going to be spider-man
home worlds now based off of everything
that we've heard so far about spider-man
3
this is kind of the perfect that's a
great title
unless you take the commentary away
from their own home universe this title
fits what's going to happen
in the movie perfectly now of course
take this with a grain of salt it may
not be the official title although it
does surely sound legitimate it
sounds perfect for tom holland to
actually reveal the official
title jimmy kimmel has actually been
teasing spider-man 3. he even tweeted
out a joke that the craving the 100th
thing yeah
seemingly confirmed that craven is
indeed going to be one of the bad guys
but of course he won't be playing craven
the hunter however it is speculated that
very very soon jimmy kimmel will have a
guest on a show
such as tom holland who will reveal the
official title
and all of this lines up really well
seems to do great for the spider-man
movies
and apparently it already has since this
writer for discussing films has already
heard it so what better way to announce
the title before it gets
out than to just go on a big television
show and announce it to the world
and this twitter account is also
claiming that it is going to be
announced
on jimmy kimmel as well so we're just
going to have to wait and see over the
next few days
but if spider-man homeworld is the
official title that would be tonight
though
it truly doesn't matter and the
appearance of
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man as well and who
knows
maybe even more like miles morales and
spider-gwen so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
details about spider-man 3
and let me know what you think about
this title spider-man homeworld in the
comments down below do you like it do
you not like it do you want the
multiverse to happen in spider-man 3 or
not
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
okay i mean yeah it's a perfect title to
me
it gave me that like perfect chill like
for
what they're setting up you want a title
that does play on it i feel like it's
not majority of people but there is a
passionate minority of people i would
say that are not enthusiastic
about this multiverse crossing over
taking you know
previous sony installments and putting
them in here i know some people are not
happy about that but i think most of us
are pretty excited for what the hell
they're gonna do
and i think to do home worlds man it
doesn't sound as sexy as spider-verse
but it's
it works perfectly for the trilogy the
culmination
it wraps it encompasses both the
multiverse
of the spider-man worlds and it also you
know it has the
the home in the title to encompass the
wrap-around for uh the trilogy
of the solo peter parker versions of
spider-man in the mcu
so i mean i think it's a it's a double
meaning kind of title oh yeah
yeah one is one that you can probably at
least glean some sort of plot theme out
of because maybe there's going to be an
element of needing to get people
back to their home worlds or something
you know we don't know we're gonna be
into the spider versus what it is
yeah yeah i i mean i don't feel like
it's gonna be the same plot but i wonder
how many similarities there will be
because of what a smash that movie was
but
every time i've heard it in this brief
few minutes of repetition
i just get that feeling of like yeah
that sounds exactly right that sounds
like what should be on the poster
yeah and i like i like it better than
homesick i like it better than home run
which i've heard some people pitch
uh yeah this is exciting and i hope i
mean you know nobody has confirmed as of
yet
that andrew garfield or toby maguire are
coming back but
it just seems super duper likely i mean
we've been
hoping for that for the longest time at
this point we've been
i've seen for like over a year now that
they have to get this done at some point
i mean who would have wanted i think
it's really funny because there's that
excitement that anticipation and the
major speculation about
jimmy kimmel having tom holland come on
to reveal the title
so this pandemic has led to
us clamoring for like give us
give us anything scrap anything please
it's like he's the image he used to go
on jimmy kimmel to unveil a trailer
and now it's one word we have a title
hood we have
we have a [ __ ] words for you
that'll hand it a theme i feel like
pre-pandemic
that'd be cool to do maybe nowhere near
as exciting
it would not be that big of a deal like
they revealed the title for end game in
the avengers endgame trailer
you know yeah and then here it's ah
this is so exciting 2020 just got a lot
better
i mean the the amount of news i've seen
over speculations on the title alone
suggests that people really do care
about what this film is called
well we wanted to know the title for so
long and i
it's kind of funny because homecoming
does have its own
double meaning to a certain extent you
know with like him coming into the mcu
also the event of actually being at home
coming
far from home implying that this is not
a new york you know
but home worlds if that is in fact the
title
and uh and this is the movie where we're
gonna get all these multiverse
crossovers and such
that's probably the most important title
you have to get right more than the
previous two
yeah it seems like you can't just call
it home run yeah exactly
exactly it seems like this title out of
all of them perhaps is the most
significant because it will relate to
more than just this movie whereas the
first two subtitles
you know they relate thematically but
they're not super important to the movie
whereas this
you know kind of signifies a pivot in
terms of
what the reality of the mcu is going to
be moving forward
so yeah it does seem like an important
title for this whole
franchise you know at the same time
though this news isn't confirmed
just yet we're probably going to learn
officially what the title is
in a day or two or maybe early next week
i'm presuming
especially if they started filming it
already but i can also imagine a world
where people
are also not thrilled at the idea that
if that this
is the title this has been a a strange
it's akin to end game in a way we're
like what's the title gonna be
what's the title gonna be then when that
title came out there was a minority
passionate voice as well that was like
i don't like that here's why you know
and let's get a petition going to change
the title i can imagine there's a
similar situation if this is called
homeworld like no that's not as good
because people have been
speculating what the title is of this
for such a long time
you know we'll get people excited
spider-man
homelander crossover boys
have them go fight each other get some
sick
twisted stuff in there as well and on a
personal note um
warren i'm a little bit nervous to go to
your comment box right now
oh yeah i'm under the impression that
there's a lot of people clowning on you
about you saying andrew mcguire yeah
as opposed to andrew holland
andrew holland the correct name yeah um
tom garfield's my favorite spider-man
and
you don't even have a pin comment no
warren what are you doing that should
have been in your pin comment warren
like i messed up i'm sorry i'm just
rushing making news
out free funko pops forever yeah every
new subscriber for
everyone gets an andrew mcguire damn it
damn it damn it
uh but no i don't blame you man i've
made worse mistakes than that on the
internet
guys if this is the official title what
do you think let us know your thoughts
down below
personally i think it's perfect uh but
i'll be curious to know what you gotta
say subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell hit the like
button if you enjoyed our video
and we'll catch you guys in the flippity
[Music]
flip
[Music]
you